while we made it folks i just finished
the eye of the world so
my thoughts are fresh in my head i loved
this book just
full stop i mean everyone has
expectations going into the series but
especially the eye of the world i feel
like there are expectations like
when you start reading people say well
just remember it's a tolkien ripoff
you know you can get through that also
like two thirds of the book are just
boring
and the ending is rushed it gives a
sense of like okay this book is i just
kind of have to trudge through it and
then
get to the other side and it really it
really wasn't like that it was a totally
different
kind of experience so first i'll be
doing a spoiler-free discussion and then
i'll be talking spoilers because i
need to talk about this book so much
happens in this book
uh like that's the first thing i want to
get off my chest and relay to others
it's like
unlike the way of kings where the way of
kings takes place in basically one main
location
two main locations pretty much the eye
of the world stretches far
a lot of new towns and experiences and
cultures and people and there's a lot
and there's a lot of
action wonderful scenes of suspense i
was surprised at some of these
suspenseful scenes and some of these
more horrific
elements there are some scary moments
that i'm
looking forward to seeing done in the
series and how they do it because i
think oh that could actually be really
disturbing
another main issue that i think people
have with
starting the wheel of time is getting
used to robert jordan's writing style
some people aren't going to vibe with
jordan's writing style and that's just
how it is i don't know i've read some
vlogs i've read moby dick twice you know
i like moby dick you have to be in the
right frame of mind for this type of
writing of course i'm a kind of person i
love
the visual information i love the
sensory details i love
the smells you know the sweat the the
grime the dirt
everything they have to go through yeah
it adds to the page count but
if you're not just looking for the plot
or story you know these
these things matter these are these are
things i like the characters in the book
i feel deeply attached to them that
if anything happens to them god forbid
um
there's gonna be issues they make some
stupid decisions
you know they're they're like kids you
know they're not kid they're young
adults
matt is definitely up there
for being stupid and stubborn but perrin
i thought perrin had a surprising
arc that i really really love
naive is a character i especially love i
i really liked naive because i could see
how she is a character like just the
basic premise of her character was
interesting to me how she is where a
wisdom is supposed to have
all this wisdom and she's really young
so she's kind of precocious but has to
defend herself
tom marilyn is a standout character for
me just
you know he's a character that you don't
expect to to love because he seems at
first like a throwaway
character that's just like oh i know
this type of character
you know that's something else i want to
say like there are so many parts in this
book that you think oh this
fantasy trope like as much as jordan
does rely on
some major fantasy tropes there's
already a lot being subverted i feel
like you know characters that we don't
expect to
to be major players or major players i
really felt like their relationships
were very realistic
and that's another point i want to get
across is that i feel like this was
a really grounded take on fantasy in a
way even though there is you know
all these tropes and very classic
fantasy elements
the way the violence is described the
way the world
is and the different factions and the
politics this is a
huge adventure there's a lot of
traveling so in some ways it reminded me
of like westerns and
and you know i i enjoy westerns because
there's a lot i enjoy the detail of
the physical just like setting up camp
you know how to deal with
horses and the ending of this book um
with no spoilers at all
um some say yeah it was it was rushed
the problem
i had a little bit with the ending was
that it was kind of
vague you know there weren't really any
definite answers
and it felt kind of like is this this
way or is this another way so if
it's slightly confusing at the end so it
makes me want to jump immediately into
the great hunt which you know i have
there's liter there's just
there are so many memorable scenes in
this book and moments that i
love character moments relationship
moments so i don't really give ratings
but um definitely one of the best
fantasy books
i've read i felt so connected to these
characters and that's kind of how i
judge
a book you know and i don't know how
i'll feel about it later on
later on in the series maybe compared to
later books i won't
you know love this book as much but if
books two and three are supposedly
better
then i'm in luck i feel like everything
i could have wanted in a fantasy book
was wrapped up neatly
in the eye of the world i mean that's my
spoiler-free review a bit all over the
place so for people who have read the
eye of the world
let's get into spoilers and let all of
the other uh
non-cool people uh exit
spoilers there's so so many moments i
want to talk about that were great
first off rand's relationship with his
father
tam tan tam so good like i just love
that relationship and he seems like such
a good father i it makes me sad
that rand has to leave and go away from
his dad but his dad is so understanding
heartbreaking when he is injured and
rand is just trying to do anything he
can to get his father healed the trolla
grade was
intense not expected out it just came
out of left field and it felt
really brutal immediately you feel like
wow okay the stakes have been
raised there's serious danger in this
world there's a lot of harm that can be
done
and then we're off on our journey i love
lan
i mean i don't think that's a
controversial take lan is
amazing i mean he's sort of hilarious in
just how stoic he is they go to berlin
bear lon berlin that first town they go
to um
that like all the edmonds fielders are
just like oh my god this is crazy
one thing i will say when they see pat
and feign the peddler
in berlin i was like this is this guy's
gonna rat them out like this is totally
a dark friend and i felt
there was one moment when i felt like
rand was being too stupid
because i was like okay this guy's
following you he's in an alley just like
oh don't tell anyone i was here
and rand is just like okay i'm sure
there's nothing weird about this
and that's another thing i feel like
people are gonna be
annoyed with them for never listening to
moraine but you have to understand it's
like to them
and i said i i sedai is like the most
evil
people the most dangerous people like
imagine that equivalent in our world and
then being like okay now you gotta trust
this person
from their perspective i totally get
that mistrust when uh
naive comes and tries to get them that i
love that because i love naive i think
she's a just a
wonderful character and funny she kind
of treats the other eminence fielders
like they're her own younger brothers
and sisters
when they get to should our lagath
shadar log
shodor shot shutter i have no idea how
to pronounce it
but the abandoned city was so great the
descriptions of the ruined town and how
it's just
still impressive even though it's
decaying matt of course
i just love the logic of you know when
matt takes the
the ruby uh dagger after afterwards
maureen is like you didn't take anything
he gave you
right you didn't take anything he gave
you they're like no
no and then matt later tyrant is like oh
yeah i got this from that
that demon and rand is like like oh we
can't you we can't take any gifts and
he's like oh no no
this he didn't hand this to me i i just
took it uh
it makes sense don't worry about it okay
like i guess we'll just not address this
and not tell moraine i'm sorry
like that was just funny when the whole
team gets separated i
that was a shock to me the stakes just
felt suddenly
really high you know they're separated
for so long in the book aguain is paired
with perrin
and what they have to go through uh
together and how
perrin is is discovering himself they
meet the traveling people and the wolves
and then they're captured by white
cloaks and it's just
i just loved those scenes matt and rand
are together which um
i think the reason people complain about
these middle scenes
when matt and rand are traveling it's
because they're kind of depressing
they're probably the most depressing
part of the book they have no money
running from mysterious people in the
scene where
um rand uses his power for the first
time but isn't
where the lightning bolt scene i loved
that because it felt like
real it felt like robert jordan had this
experience at like a crappy
hotel or bar in his own life and
transcribed it but in a fantasy setting
rand and matt can tell like they're
gonna get robbed but they can't really
do anything they're already in this
inn they can't make a seed it's just so
sketchy things keep escalating and then
there's the dark friend is there too so
it's just even more trouble
then we have that great moment of the
lightning bolt it just was a badass
moment tom marilyn i
i don't know what happens with tom it's
hinted very heavily that he survived
which i mean you gotta just trust
but tom when he sacrificed himself for
random it's like oh man i love tom
marilyn and he's like he cares like they
don't even realize how much
tom is caring about them like he's
literally like on the boat
training them how to be gleaming in case
they need to like just in case you know
and then giving him
them their tools so that they if they
didn't have tom's
training while they were on the ship
they would not survive they would not
make it through
to camel and they wouldn't go anywhere
and when they get to kamlyn oh man
is it is it great and we meet loyal who
is wonderful
one of the scenes i was surprised by of
course is when logan comes in
the false dragon seems so out of left
field and accidental that was kind of
annoying like oh this kind of
coincidence can't just happen it just so
happens that rand is climbing up onto a
wall and falls into
the um palace garden or whatever and he
meets uh elaine and gwyn
i believe that's their names there's
like this power dynamic going on between
the aya sedai and the palace
absolute favorite scene in the book i
think is when the whole
team gets back together when moraine uh
naive
and gwen and lan and heron finally
come to the end where rand and matt are
that so great and it just
felt they've been separated for so long
and it just keeps getting better like
you know you think you know what's going
to happen from here and then they go to
the ways and i had no idea there was
going to be portal hopping or and stuff
quick travel so early on in a series you
know the blight
i loved reading about uh people say it's
rushed but i thought we spent a good
amount of time in the blight i mean i
felt like i didn't want to spend any
more time there i'm in la there's a heat
wave going on
i was reading this and i'm like sweating
i'm like can we just get out of the
blight like i'm hot enough as it is i
don't need to be reading about how
impossibly hot it is in the blight the
green man
was great oh man the way he died would
just made me so sad
the one thing like when rand goes into
his like
seeing balzemon and it was sort of
confusing and jarring and he it
basically
wields the one power i'm looking forward
to book two because i need some more
context
rand thinks he killed bowzamon and it's
kind of funny to me because rand's like
i did it right moraine you know he's
he's done and marine's like yeah
sure yeah obviously he's not gone
i thought it was a little weird how you
know naive and equine and moraine and
land know about rand
wielding this power but the others don't
i don't know how i feel about that it's
a lot it's a lot in an ending
and it's jam-packed it makes me want to
instantly read the other book in fact
i want to be reading it right now
instead of recording this so i'm
probably going to
i don't think i have any other thing i
want to talk about it surpassed my
expectations
i really care about what's going to
happen
but i also felt like i got a full
thorough fantasy story like i feel like
if i read this
when it first came out and there wasn't
another one i would have been like damn
that was that was satisfying i got i got
my money's worth
you know that that felt like a full
fleshed out fantasy story so much
happened
a lot of development it felt complete
but it also left me wanting more
and that's what you want to do folks so
thank you for um for watching thank you
yeah have a good one
you